Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
This is my full video for the boys
Gen V Episode 7
There were a whole bunch of Easter Eggs
and references.
We only have one episode left too
so probably a couple of big cameos
from the regular main Boys series.
They also said that the finale is meant
to directly set up the boys season 4.
There were a couple moments
during this episode where they referenced
some storylines and plot
that will take place
during the boys season four.
so if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes.
I will be doing more videos for the boys
Season 4 after Gen V is done.
We'll start hearing a little bit more
about that pretty soon.
careful for spoilers for the episode.
If you haven't seen it
yet, we'll just start at the beginning
and work our way through shot by shot.
Talking about Easter eggs in WTF moments,
starting with the episode Title six,
which is mostly just a reference
to the anti superhero v*rus that Dr.
Cardoza is testing on the superheroes
and then winds up getting to victory.
Newman At the end of the episode,
the actual opening scene is Dr. Cardoza
making the compound v virus more contagious.
As he says it requires direct contact
or bodily fluid extreme.
seems to like cough in someone's face
or like literally spit on them.
some sort of transmission of blood.
Like if you got into a giant brawl
with someone, like they're teasing.
There's going to be in the finale.
is just as deadly as it was last week,
even though the dean is trying to make
it more deadly.
But she says she wants to make it airborne
so that it's even more contagious
and will kill all superheroes.
We talked about this in previous episodes,
so it's not meant to be a big revelation
or anything like that.
Like she wants to kill all superheroes.
they didn't give all these superheroes
names.
They just called this girl bald girl,
this guy Andy.
So we don't know what
all their powers were.
there's also this weird thing
in the episode where they try to make Dr.
Cardoza seem a little more sympathetic
by having him oppose Dean Sherri,
when she wants to make it airborne,
like it sounds like he figured out
what her plan was a while ago
and he's been waiting
to confront her on it.
But he hasn't gone to Vought yet
because he legit thinks that
they'll kill him because he created this.
here's the thing, though.
If Stan Edgar were still in charge of
like he's not in charge of right now,
at least that we know of,
he'd probably be very interested in
something like this, like a fatal anti
superhero weapon, a deterrent
that he could just put on ice in some deep
vault somewhere if he needed to use it,
if someone was too powerful
to kill or control the old fashioned way.
but I think the whole idea
with the doctors,
they want to make him seem like this
misguided scientist was just thinking
all about the research
and not like the moral ramifications
or like the larger ramifications
of what he's actually doing.
either way,
he kind of came off like a dirt bag.
So I didn't feel too sorry for him.
When Victoria Neuman popped his head
at the end of the episode,
it even though Dean said he keeps hyping
this up as being super powerful,
like killing all superheroes,
I still don't think that is going
to be powerful enough
to actually kill Homelander
like, that's literally
how powerful he's meant to be.
the only person on the boys.
I think there's going to be strong.
Have to kill him will be Ryan.
I talked about this
a lot in previous videos
like they want him to seem
like he is almost unkillable.
That's why Victoria Newman isn't
supposed to be able to pop
is like she's super powerful.
She can pop, anyone says.
Except for Homelander
that's one of the darker parody
aspects of the whole boys universe,
like the comics and the TV show.
What would you do if there was a Superman
who was unkillable?
Like he was invincible and he was evil?
how would you stop someone like that
if there was no way to actually kill them
Victorian Newman doesn't
want to kill all superheroes but she does
want to neutralize probably
also eventually get rid of Homelander
or use a deterrent against him,
even if he doesn't plan on
actually using it against him.
You don't actually have to kill
Homelander.
You just have to make him think
that you might be able to kill him.
That's why at the end of the episode
she tells Cardoza,
Is it okay if I steal your line there?
Compassionate control she wants to use.
The virus is a method for control.
but in her own personal way,
like behind the scenes,
not in the public way
that Vought is planning on using it,
she clearly has no intention
of taking it to Vought
or informing them that it actually exists.
one of the other
big revelations of the episode
was the Dean Shetty's daughter
and her husband were on the flight.
Homelander destroyed it during season
one, the infamous flight.
It was a great episode.
may have also threatened
to use the footage from that against him
in season two.
they actually confirmed my theory
about Din Shetty, like she referenced that
she used to have a daughter.
And my theory was,
is that she died because of some
collateral damage incident.
But they made it a much bigger thing
in this episode
than I thought it was going to be like
it was Homelander
who was directly responsible
for their deaths in why she infiltrated
the college and wants to use this virus
to kill all superheroes.
She goes on and on about
the whole collateral damage of it all.
They actually got into this
during the boys
season one
where they're talking to these other city
like other governmental figures, saying
that will bring superheroes to your town.
But they also caused so much
collateral damage that the joke of it
is it almost winds up
costing other cities money.
Vought tries to sell them
on bringing superheroes to their city
and then using the superhero
to make more money
for the local government.
But it winds up costing them more money
because of all the damage that they cause.
this is one of the main reasons why
Stan Eggar was trying to phase the company
out of the superhero business,
so to speak, like basically mothball
all superheroes,
but in a much less bloody way.
he wanted to start selling
the temporary compound
to the military through the government,
and it'd be way more profitable for them
because it would not cause
the same collateral damage.
There's this was just a lot of daily
headaches in dealing with all superheroes.
Like just imagine all the headaches
that Homelander causes for them.
now imagine that time's like a thousand
That's why Vought was using the woods for
in the first place to develop a virus to
control superheroes, but not to kill them.
they also confirmed that Marie's
mystery benefactor was Victoria Neuman
in the reason
why she helped her get into good
and was because
she had a soft spot for her
because she also has blood bending powers
and came up through Red River.
but really, as she revealed to her,
she was just doing her solid, short term,
long term victory.
Neuman Sounds like she wants to put Marie
on the Seven and use her position
to influence is a powerful superhero
to help Victorian women
do whatever she wants to do in the future,
basically creating her own
little cabal of superheroes
that will just do
whatever she tells them to do.
They also reveal the nature of Victoria
Neuman's powers.
It's more than just head popping.
She has regular blood bending powers, but
they don't get too deep into the weeds.
On how powerful she is.
I think the idea is that Maria's
mentally more powerful than she is.
maybe they'll have a blood
bending battle like Avatar
The Last Airbender during the finale
where Victoria Newman is trying to use her
powers and Marie tries to neutralize her
while she's using her powers to
that was literally the plot of one of
the Avatar, The Last Airbender episodes.
there are also a couple of teasers
for the boys
Season four that
she dropped during her conversations.
I'll talk about those
when we get to that part of the episode.
the Scooby Gang make their plan
to deal with the dean using Kate's access.
Maria and Jordan split off
to go to her office and get more details,
accidentally getting more information
than they planned on from a very drunk
Cardoza. dessert.
This whole arc for Kate in the episode
where she kind of goes off the deep end
and starts acting more like a villain.
Normally, I would say she's an Emma
Frost X-Men parody,
but there were a couple of moments
in the trailer for the finale
that seemed like they were direct
parodies of scenes from X-Men Dark Phenix.
Were Jean Gray going for Phenix,
Jordan and Marie
passed by a ton of Easter eggs
and references to the boys main series.
In the seven characters,
there's posters for an A-Train
ad for a meal replacement drink.
This is in Turbo Rush.
It's meant to be some other company
called Henderson.
there's the campaign poster
for Victoria Newman and Robert
Singer giving them the idea to go to her
with the evidence of the weapon.
the whole Super Lives
matter is a reference to Black Lives
Matter in real life.
And there are a ton of posters
of the seven characters
just in general
like this is a black noir poster.
R.I.P.
It seems like they're ads for Apple
parody products of sort stuff.
We'll see if Black Noir winds up
coming back in some way
during the boys season four
or like the boys season five.
they can actually legit do that
like in the comics.
Vought
actually is able to bring compounding
superheroes back to life by
just dosing them with more compound
B, But when they come back to life,
they're kind of like mindless shells.
But that was already kind of the way
they were using the black noir character.
Like he was sort of a finger puppet
for Stan Edgar.
this one's Homelander.
This one's Crimson Countess.
There's a lot of crimson
Countess all over the Boys Gen V series,
but that's mostly because they named
the theater school after her.
there's also another A-Train
ad for a beer brand that they're drinking.
Later in the episode that I'll point out
the joke
here, though, with them going to Victoria
Neuman instead of Vought, though,
is that they think Vought will spin things
to their benefit, lie to the public,
which is totally true.
Ashley does that all the time.
They've been posting all kinds of boys
season four promos, but they're doing that
mostly about Homelander
standing trial for killing that dude
at the end of season three,
which they also reference
during this episode. Do.
but the big twist that obviously
they haven't figured out yet
is that Victoria
Neuman is just as bad as bought in.
For a long time.
She was working for Vought for Stan Edgar
when he was still at Vought in order
to try and gain a foothold in the White
House and gain control over the government
so that they could control public policy
like that would give them real power
if they could actually influence laws
that were created, they could basically do
whatever they want to get away with,
anything they wanted to
versus started out with Vought
trying to get superheroes in the military.
Now it's Vought trying to get superheroes
in the White House
and into the government this way.
When Maria reveals everything to her,
she's like, You know what?
I'll take care of it, don't worry.
And she's going to take care of it.
But in her own way, where she spins things
to her benefit and lies to the public
the same way the thought would do it
just now that Victoria Neuman
is serving her own interests
and not so much a boss interests, it's
just sometimes her interests
happened to be aligned with Vos interests
She's meant to be a parody of the AOC
character
the show could parody both conservatives
like the alt right
in America and also parody
the left politically.
we're talking about American politics here
like everybody in different countries
has their own version of this dichotomy.
but the boys TV show is taking shots
at both sides
saying that the left
and the right are equally bad.
No one is better than the other.
that's why during the episode,
she wears the blue colors
for the political left and Cameron wears
red for the political right
because the show is meant to be a parody
of conservative right wing talk shows.
the other funny detail, too,
is that she wears blue to reference
that she is a compounded superhero
secretly working for Ward in compound B
is blue like metaphorically and literally.
She's showing her true colors.
they're couple funny moments with Emma
and Sam hiding out in her dorm room.
Her banter about casual, everyday
superhero life sounds pretty accurate
to what it would be like
if superheroes like this actually existed.
Like, does it do to my class
that I know that will burn all our stuff?
He has Pyro Powers.
All we got to do is give him some drugs.
you had to imagine
if kids with superpowers like this existed
and they were regulated
or not regulated the way that they aren't.
In the boys universe,
people would act like this all the time.
just using your powers
for all kinds of everyday, mundane stuff
they make a reference to her
Starlight v*brator
There was a joke about those kinds of toys
during the boys season three.
The whole idea is that will merchandise
literally any part
of their superheroes,
anything at all just to make more money.
in when Sam starts poring through all of
her stuff, like her underwear drawer,
all that stuff around her room, it's
meant to be reference back to Homelander
doing the same thing
during the boys season two
because both of them are kind of mentally
and emotionally stuck
in this childhood state Because they were
both treated the same way growing up.
Growing up in isolation,
basically locked up
when they were children is basically
why homelander so messed up in present day
inside the dean's office.
The painting above the door
is of Guadalcanal.
The man who founded the college,
which they later
revealed was a clinical psychologist
for Vought,
who created the school, is a front
just for studying compound superheroes.
So the whole joke is that you
don't come to the school to learn.
The school brings you there
so that it can study you.
that's
also why there's a painting of Woods
next to his painting to reference
the Woods facility underneath the college.
But if it wasn't clear,
he founded the college working for Vought.
So like, it was a thought
that actually started the college.
they find the dean's records
of the flight.
That home later
destroyed the names of her daughter,
her husband
listed on the passenger list, confirming
they died because of what Homelander did.
the whole idea of Cardoza barging in
all drunk, I think is kind of convenient.
Mostly so that the kids can actually learn
what's going on with the virus.
Like fatal.
What's going on? Contagious. my God.
We got to do something about this.
but here's the thing. The other thing,
He doesn't hear it.
Basically piss in her alcohol bottle.
I'm hoping that they pay
that off in the finale by having somebody
accidentally drink that.
maybe someone like Rufus,
because Rufus said that he worked
inside the dean's office.
And if you're going to have
someone take that, well,
why not make it be Rufus
just because he's such a dirtbag
then we get our next
big cameo scene from the boys main series
Jedi meets with Mallory, hoping to get her
help with her plan to kill superheroes.
During their conversation,
she also references Butcher and the boys
After the conversation,
she speaks to someone on her comm
who was listening in saying
that they should tell the dean
that could have been butcher
that she was talking to
so he might have a cameo at some point
during the finale or other boys
characters.
Probably homelander too,
just because they reference Homelander
so many times in this episode.
the reason why Mallory doesn't want her
weapon
is because she doesn't
want to commit genocide.
And that's basically what she's talking
about doing, killing all superheroes.
And there are a lot of compounded
superheroes
that have lame powers
or like barely any powers
and aren't really doing anything
or causing any kind of collateral damage.
it's really only like
a small chunk of them
that are super destructive
in the really bad ones, said.
He also says they need ten more months
to make the virus contagious and airborne.
So because Victoria Neuman gets it
at the end of the episode,
I think the idea is that it
hasn't become airborne yet.
Like it's still very dangerous,
but not nearly as dangerous
as the data wanted to make it there,
a couple of funny moments
with Sam getting caught up in the party
in the hallway, swept up in the fun of
just being a normal kid,
just having a good time,
not being worried about someone
trying to rip him apart
or experiment on him or lock him up.
it's not totally clear
why Rufus lies to him about Emma.
He might have just been trying
to mess with him for like,
he just wanted to have fun
by messing with anybody.
And he just happened to walk in
with Field of Vision, like, Yeah,
sure, Emma's over at the place
where we're going.
I don't think Rufus was playing
any kind of four dimensional chess
or anything like that.
Had some secret plot.
He was just messing with him.
zoom in enhanced
when they're partying there.
The beer that they're drinking
is the same brand as Atrians.
Advertisement.
Earlier in the episode,
probably a brand that owns
one of the other jokes, too, about the Boy
series is like all the different products
that you see people are using are owned
by Vought in some way,
like they keep referencing
Vought a burger in the episodes then
when Andre's father, Polarity, has his
freak out, losing control of his powers.
I think the idea is that he's
having a bad reaction to compound, be
like he's having a heart attack,
basically.
they kind of got into
this whole phenomenon with Atrians Heart
during the Boys season three.
The whole idea is
the compound is super volatile.
It kills most people who take it,
even the younger children.
if you survive the initial treatment
and get powers,
you can take more of it in small doses
with all kinds of crazy side effects.
Like some people use it as a regular drug.
Some people use it to enhance
their powers.
More like A-Train was the more you do that
the more of a toll
it takes on your body like real world
performance enhancing drugs.
So early theory, that's kind of
what's going on with Andre's father,
like his body shutting down
because of a bad compound reaction.
They basically use this plot
to reunite Andre with him.
And I think they're trying to imply
that had he not left Kate, Kate
would not have flown off the deep end.
they basically wind up taking him
to vaults doctors at Vought Tower.
That's where they're at in these scenes
here.
there's like a real brief,
funny moment for things get really crazy
where Emma accidentally cock blocks
maverick who's in the middle of something
really nasty with that donkey of his
who's kind of his girlfriend.
I'm still not totally clear
if that's like a compound view superhero
that just looks like a donkey
or it's just a regular old donkey.
you can let me know in the comments
like, is I just a regular donkey?
Then at the political conference,
most of these Perry's are pretty obvious
like Rufus is red Hat is a reference
to Trump's Make America great slogan
The superhero students are to riot
because they buy into Victorian Newman's
rhetoric in her lies,
thinking that she's anti super because
she's kind of there representing the BSA,
which was the agency
that they created to regulate superheroes.
But the whole idea is that she lies
like she makes
everybody think that she doesn't
have compound superpowers.
They referenced the Stormfront tirade
during season two.
Then soldier boy is damage
in season three.
Then they start teasing stuff
for the boys. Season four.
So one of the students
asks about Homelander
standing trial for killing that dude
at the end of season three.
Victoria Neuman suggests
that he will see to imagine like
Batman v
Superman, where Superman attends Congress.
the only problem with something like that,
though, is Homelander
would never let anyone put him in prison.
Like he would flip out
and destroy everything in sight
before something like that happened.
They even teased that earlier on the boys
when he was with Victoria Neuman.
the other big teaser for season four
is that Victoria Newman says that
when she becomes vice president,
like she's very sure of this,
the government is going
to create a position for superheroes,
for someone like Homelander
to sit on a council with her
and other government leaders
like the President, the vice president,
and have a say in public policy.
that's what's true goal like.
That was Stan Edgar's goal to basically
get a foothold in the White House
so they could influence public policy
because the Vought controlled
the government
like get superheroes in the government,
they could basically get away
with anything that they want.
there's a ton of powers.
They show off when the kids start rioting.
Most of them are parodies of X-Men powers,
like there's a Sonic Scream, like Havoc
or Banshee. There's some laser eyes.
this girl who was ice isolating was Sam
earlier has purple glowing eyes.
There's a girl with green fire.
She seems like more of a Green Lantern
parody
when things really start
getting crazy. Rufus References.
Homelander Again, making it seem like
he will cameo in the finale In Jordan.
Helps Marie sneak into the conference
by distracting the guards with a brawl.
She starts with the girl who expose Emma
for clout on her social media,
just clocking the hell out of her.
Victorian woman
basically reveals everything to Marie.
I've already talked a little bit
about this during the video,
but the idea is
that she went to Red River.
She helped her get into Good Dogan
because she was trying to do her solid,
but also set her up as somebody
that she could use in the future
as muscle, basically
creating her own team of loyal superheroes
that will just do
whatever she tells them to do.
she basically explains her long term plan
for Marie
is to get her on the seven
and use that power to their benefit.
And also she be able to use that
to find her sister.
They keep teasing her sister,
but they might save that for season two.
We'll see if Marie actually winds up
getting a shot at making it onto the seven
they've already renewed the show
for season two,
and they're calling it sophomore year.
So like she still has
a number of years left in college
to finish before she would join the seven.
then Kate goes for Emma Frost,
White Queen on Dean, Sherri
forcing her to reveal everything.
The Scooby Gang then kill herself.
And she goes to the dorms
with another group of superheroes
that are getting worked up
from the conference
to try and cause some real damage, destroy
the woods.
this might be how they explain Homelander
showing up during the finale.
Like, the whole idea is that the kids
start causing so many problems that Vought
can't ignore it, like they can't hide.
so they might wind up
sending some of the seven like homelander
in to put the kibosh on it.
Homelander basically squishing a couple
of the kids until they all chill out.
Then we get that quick tag scene
at the end with Victoria Neuman tricking
Cardoza into handing over the virus
and killing him by popping his head.
R.I.P.
like I said earlier, the theory right now
is that she'll just use it as a deterrent,
but it might become a big plot point
during the finale.
the other early theory is that she
might use it to try and kill Homelander,
but I think she has bigger plans for it,
like she wants to keep it around
just in case
you might need it in the future.
just in case anybody gets in her way
there are bunch of Easter eggs
and references in the episode.
So if he spotted any
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments
in my full finale video we'll post
next week after they release it,
they haven't said when the boys season
four is going to premiere.
My assumption is going to be sometime
like spring or summer next year.
But for the most part season four
is about done.
Like it's kind of sitting on a shelf.
They're polishing the special effects.
That's about it.
rear in the middle of Loki season
two episodes right now.
But like the next real big thing
that's going to start
next week is Invincible Season 2
And it's probably one of the best
superhero series next to the boys.
click.
Here for my full Loki Season
2 Episode 4 Video
and click here for my Invincible Season
2 trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!